the right hand of brazier's first major
league start how about that first major
league startup
he shoots it up the right side toward
the corner
of fairball
cloud's gonna turn and head for second
base and he is in there
ahead of the throw two bases for brandon
loud taking the mound for the raise is
gonna be left-hander ryan yarbrough his
fourth start of the season looking for
that first win
and that's gonna be a base hit and a
right so verdugo drops in a single he's
now two for three in his career against
yarborough so red sox trying to jump on
yarbrough right away he's winless in his
last 11 starts
blind drive that one hit to left headed
for the wall it's high off the monster
burdugo is in to score
jd martinez
is into third base and it's an rbi
double for xander bogarts who continues
to pick on tampa bay
ground ball yanked to short trying to
send a runner home he hesitates goes to
first and got him
but the red sox will bring in another
run as martinez scores
and his 3-1 pitch
and one punch through for a base head
bogart's in to score
and the red sox take a three to nothing
lead in the first inning
this one away and a long fly ball to
center and a leap before karemeier gets
to the wall and makes the catch he was a
couple steps away from the wall and
probably not quite sure where that wall
was
but he's making the leaping catch to
retire the hitter anyway
yeah and and
he didn't really need to leap left a
little bit too soon and you could tell
by his reaction when he got up he
realized
now the rudder headed to second
the pitch up and meadows
picks up his first stolen base of the
year
oh oh martinez launches a high deep
drive and that ball is way out of fenway
park
jd martinez for the first time
i've said i didn't give it up
it is four to one red sox jd martinez
absolutely smoked it see if that gets
him going boy did he need that
that is up the middle backhanded nicely
loud a very good play right there to get
that throw away to g-man choi and retire
xander bogart i'm gonna tell you what
this place is better than it even looked
that ball off the mound the short hop
the way that he got to his feet slide
pop-up slide and then get rid of it all
in one motion
now the pitch has popped into center out
of the reach
of bogarts
matsugo will score
kermire will cross the plate
perez drops that one in there the rays
have two runs
home and make it a one-run game it's 4-3
oh two skied in the center field with
some carry that ball off the bottom of
the wall out there perez hitting third
they're gonna wave him home
the throw to the plate will be
too late and into third base
goes meadows
well there there's a lot happening here
and ron rennicky's going to want to take
a look at that play at the plate here it
is throws there in time but look at the
little juke action and the left hand
gets to the back corner of home plate
check he kind of pulled up on it so
here's the answer he's out
he's gonna turn it over
two and one to count on joey wendell
wendell lines it back into center
bradley on the run over his head and one
hop to the wall
diaz digging hard on his way to the
plate he will score and all the way to
third goes wendell and the rays have
tied this game at four joey wendell
comes through
it's gonna go up in the middle and there
it is for a base hit get the baseball
jonathan arrows with his first major
league hit he does it tonight against
tampa bay at fenway
and hit on the ground shortstop wendell
lau one joy
two the rays get the double play
six four three and get out of that spot
he shoots it up the right side fair ball
down beyond the tarp picked up by pilar
one run is in
the rays are going to take the lead
perez crosses the plate diaz winds up at
third and g-man choi comes through to
make it 5-4 ray
is the breaking ball but he got it down
the line it's going to drop in and carry
him off the sidewall here comes chamussy
reddit he is in to score and the red sox
have tied at 5-5 on the base hit by
plawecki what a piece of hitting there
one none out tied at five in the seven
springs against kiermeier
and a base hit into left center field
going to go all the way to the wall
desugo will score margaux heads to the
plate
he's going to score a two-run double for
kier meyer and the rays grab the lead
again it's 7-5
throw down to second base runner on the
move and got him what
cut him down
now they're thinking about taking a look
at this and challenging the play
was he touching him on the back like and
he thinks he thinks he's safe meadows
a little bit i say it's safe right we've
got an answer
wrong again thank you
we've scored seven so far
and there's a shot in the left that ball
is going to be off the wall
adamus
will score bronzo winds up at third
and margot's having quite a night
banging that one off the green monster
driving it around
runners lead all the way around in a 1-1
line drive and that one's into the alley
one run in here comes and tendy in the
score that is a two-run hit ara ooze has
had himself a knight and the red sox
have closed the gap to one yeah the
biggest at bat of his career here's
chavis one-two pitch from kidridge
swing and a miss and that will do it
foul tipped into the mid to strike him
out so this one ends after almost four
and a half hours tampa bay hangs on to
win it eight to seven the final score